[Narrator] Now it turns out this is not an easy thing to do.
An obvious idea might be to complete all this normalized alphas,
but you still have to be able to sample from those.
So, in the spectrum of our alphas you might draw a random variable
uniformly from the interval 0;1, and then find out the alpha
so that all the alphas leading up to it, and some are smaller than beta,
but if we add the new alpha to the sum you would get a value larger than beta.
Now that's doable. It's inefficient.
In the best case you get an N* log(N) implementation.
Let me show you what is commonly done, and I don't take any guarantee
that it's entirely unbiased, but there's a very simple trick.